you're Indian yeah well your shoes hurt
my eyes your shoes hurt know what
they're so flimsy I know to give it away
no cuz you know what it is you've ran
them to the bottom I will there of my
Wolverine thousand-mile errs and I I
split wood with him I do man [ __ ] you
pose in those don't you
shiny shears buddy how do you come with
Buzz Aldrin's
what would you just wake up and decide
to put those on sounds wrong no Louie
but done oh they're so expensive
oh no yeah bro but are they designed by
NASA they expensive I don't know they
give them to you for fun I don't know
Brian I don't believe it I think you
spent crazy money on them when would I
I don't know it was out of town bro me
did it online yeah I think you broke out
I don't think so see if you can get
these online I want some silver shoes to
go with my space suit you'll learn one
day dude it's about being an influencer
sure your figure uh-huh I'm too old year
old and I get I'm just too off it's not
you don't use a fifty two-year-old to
model your you just don't knock on
clarity's best club top five for me
all-time great that place love Nick love
very will involve green room awful green
room yeah so there was I remember this
is a transgender show going on what he
called it a burlesque show right yeah
but I was there with a kid Oh dick sent
its shows the Gay Pride yes I why there
yes sir so Wallace on Derrick and I are
walking around we look like the most
gender you're you guys we went now you
got the cultural gays around so I'm get
all these views I'm they're just i
bombed that morning it's like the United
Nations a [ __ ] for you guys yeah I look
just like a giant Cuban baseball player
yeah yeah we're getting weird looks dude
anyways that was the back of that that
was the that was the greenroom
well there's a good headdress on him he
looks like we had to share the dress
room with him he looks like somebody put
a glasses on a flamingo
I could not look like more like a bunny
I got giant chest here yeah he's a bird
Hey there is nothing better than when we
come when we come into town and he's on
his tinder app looking for girls oh
don't say it out loud can you oh yeah
what do you mean it's gonna help him out
he's single dude it's great
and he's swiping it's great oh yeah me
and Derrick just go through and tell him
to swipe right and swipe left it is so
interesting a lot of girls are
interested in the indian guy yeah yeah
until he gets a little more a little
famous and they see how fun that's what
I told him
yeah I said you think Aziz is worried
about that bro ah bro
now she got you a little more famous
mm-hmm plenty of sorry plenty of young
ladies be all over that Indian dong
Indian pipe we're looking forward that
goes me into that Indian chapati chapati
you know which is something that is
super Indian I thought these are Indian
chapatis are basically flatbread there
yeah so ins give me all over that land
deck that Aladdin's Indian all of the
earth your Indian samosa what's super
Indian what's some Indian dude there's a
chapati I don't know the Indian culture
I'm embarrassed I know Indian food very
well it's religious this dad I'm trying
to tell my investment dude make a food
truck you and your dad uh-huh
is that well hold on the dad's a NASA
scientist so he didn't give a [ __ ] and
I'll saw I'm a comic man but I know but
you do a food truck oh my god his mom's
a millionaire too yeah hi Lee I Drummond
Family Dollar educated he's the
disappointment I think well he'll
probably be very successful he's funny
right so dude yeah funny
yeah funny he's one of these young dudes
[ __ ] dancers if I'm never going to
come [ __ ] married but would love to
[ __ ] a dancer like a little kind of
dancer like a JLo oh yeah I want someone
but ethnic am i right guys
yes all right I want someone who can
read my timing so when she does this I
don't like time in with
we're both moving at the same time
that's what my rhythm of the night -
yeah I need someone to read my energy to
lead me yeah black girl mm-hmm did you
say you need a white girl who it's rare
though you know that's hip-hop you know
horde broke a figure it out - I wouldn't
mind don't work yeah my wife's getting
laser treatment on her face and it's
working has it be she looks so lucky
your wife is a beautiful accent girls do
have like a little bit of mustaches oh
dude I dated a girl I won't say her name
cuz you works at Disney now yeah I gotta
end this story right now dude how do
they not notice how they'd not wake up
Mike I'll [ __ ] I need to I'm ashamed
what's yours what's the equivalent of
that for men you know brows are like
long nose hairs right or like long nose
hairs are a problem you bet how do you
not notice or if you have just [ __ ]
breath a really bad tease terrible they
come on a black tooth right here that
guy's just changed colors and I gotta
get stressed ya know the best thing
about going gold yab you'd look sick
with just a solid right in a weird spot
I told someone I was molested and I
didn't realize I had been molested yeah
yeah yeah I was like oh that counted
like that's how [ __ ] safe I was it's
this story I was I was running a how
deep into it I was running a half
marathon with jim Florentine
and I get was how many concussions do
you think you had I said oh I probably
had a few and he goes really I said I
once so bad they had to wake me up every
hour and feel my testicles he was like
uh-huh and I was like yeah like that's
how bad it was like that wake me up and
feel my testicles and dick like every
hour and he was like Danny hey man I
think you were molested and I was like
what he was like I think you were
molested I go no no not a god that's
like they give you a physical he goes
number they just wake you up
they just right yeah I was we were
running I laughed so hard I was like
I was like wait was I I was molested and
we laughed so and he's like I can't
believe you never do that yeah well
whatever see if you can get hard cuz it
there's a parasympathetic dude frontal
medial cortex
I have no like I didn't hold me back it
didn't bother me and we laughed
hysterically and I was like are you
serious and he was like the look on his
face made me dial up he goes you know
when you when you get a concussion they
don't have to bill your balls at all but
yeah I grew up very safe I mean I think
that's the problem with me is that like
I die I'm everything they hate about
white privilege I go oh yeah like we
were I was saying this to you the other
night I go I'm so shocked people care
about things as much like I don't care
about [ __ ] anything like like I just
go oh yeah me x matter Oh Tom - got a
new phone numbers I gave his phone
number out on stage one night did you
really wrong yeah no he doesn't know
that totally does now but he knows it
Lee knows a little bit now I don't think
this will get to him you guys can keep a
secret right some people have no one's
listening I got drunk and I called him
it I was doing a Cossack to work show in
Tampa and I got drunk and I called him
and I went to voicemail at all of us to
leave our voice Melanie because the
number is two one and I just gave it out
I didn't realize I was so drunk I was so
drunk you don't hear how drunk I was
that I'd never get a drink on stage I do
drink on stage every now and then but
for the most part I'm stone sober on
stage you really I don't like to drink
on stage especially if I'm doing like my
theater cool huh so I get done this show
if you can find pictures of it on
Facebook I do the mean greed I am so but
I'm blackout drunk
I'm blackout drunk I ended the show and
they're yelling the Machine and I go no
I'm [ __ ] done he's off the mic and
walked away right I go I do the meet and
greet I'm blackout drunk I wake up in a
house what city is this Tampa wake up in
a house I've never been in in my entire
[ __ ] I get up and I'm in a bed I'm
Mike oh my god I'm totally naked my
clothes are on the ground that ain't
gonna do the first thing I do is I look
around and I'm like I go where's my
wallet where's my
like I don't have anything I don't have
my backpack I got nothing
it's like four o'clock in the afternoon
please call in sick to work shows I used
to do happen to Levin I do radio I drink
it radio I go in we drink for the show
it would be chaos right they get done it
too we'd stay at the bar and drink I get
up in this house and I walk out I've
jeans on now and I'm like Hello
no one's there hello never seen this
house in my life I'm walking around and
I'm like it's a really nice house and
I'm like is anybody here the phone rings
you have no kidney the phone rings I
don't answer it I'm like [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no
I grabbed my phone I look at my location
where I am on my map I have no I'm in
like such a weird part of Tampa I'm like
shot and I go up and tap on my shut the
[ __ ] up
I look around there's pictures of me up
in the [ __ ] mantle and I'm like how
they have [ __ ] pictures of me like as
a kid you're at superfans house the door
opens my parents are bought a new house
and I [ __ ] forgot about it when I was
in their new house I've never seen it I
was like yeah that's yeah Tampa Connell
do this call in sick to work shows
anymore